[موسيقى]
وحده الاوروبيين على المحكه بسبب اوكرانيا
والنيتو امام اختبار صعب بعد تهديدات
الروسيه اما البنتاجون يحذر من نقص مخزون
السلاح الامريكي والصين تستمر في تطوير
ترسانتها العسكريه هذه الملفات وغيرها
نناقشها معكم في حلقه اليوم اهلا بكم في
عسكريتانيا
[موسيقى]
القوات الجويه الامريكيه اعلنت التعاقد مع
شركه بوينج لشراء 15 طائره من طراز كيا
ليصل بذلك اجمالي طائرات كي سي بارتي
المخصصه لمهام التزود بالوقود في الجو
وكذلك النقل الاستراتيجي التي تعاقدت
عليها القوات الجويه الامريكيه الى 128
طائره تسلمت القوات الجويه الامريكيه منها
بالفعل 68 طائره حتى الان من المتوقع ان
يتم تسليم هذه الدفعه الاخيره من الطائرات
بنهايه اغسطس من عام 2006 كما تعاقدت
القوات الجويه الامريكيه ايضا مع الشركه
لشراء 10 طائرات من نفس الطراز لدول شركه
منها ست طائرات لليابان واربع طائرات
لاسرائيل يذكر ايضا ان اليابان تسلمت
بالفعل اول طائرتين من طراز كي سي فاس
في اطار سعي الكويت لتعزيز قدراتها الجويه
تعاقدت وزاره الدفاع الكويتيه مع شركه
بايكار التركيه للحصول على مسيرات بيركتار
في صفقه بلغت قيمتها 370 مليون دولار
وبهذا تكون دوله الكويت هي الدوله الثامنه
والعشرين التي تحصل على هذه المسيره التي
اكتسبت شهره كبيره بعد الحرب بين ارمينيا
واذربيجان وكذلك بعدما استخدمها
الاوكرانيون في الحرب ضد روسيا
اسرائيل تسعى لتعزيز قدراتها الجويه
الهجوميه بطائرات من طراز اف 15 اي اكس
ايجل والتي تنتجها شركه الامريكيه الطائره
التي تعد النسخه الاحدث من مقاتلات اف 15
تتميز بانها الاكثر قدره على حمل الاسلحه
في فئتها كما يمكنها ان تطلق صواريخ تفوق
سرعتها سرعه الصوت يذكر ايضا ان تل ابيب
كانت قد عززت قدرتها الجويه باسطول من
المقاتلات اف 35 الشبحيه كما انها تعمل
كذلك على تطوير اسطولها من طائرات اف 15
اي وبحسب الخبراء فان التحديثات
الاسرائيليه الجديده تاتي في اطار سعيها
لامتلاك القوه اللازمه لاستهداف المواقع
النوويه الايرانيه وكذلك تحسبا لامكانيه
امتلاك ايران لطائرات سخوي 35 او منظومه
اس 400 روسي
[موسيقى]
منذ البدايه شكلت الحرب في اوكرانيا
امتحانا صعبا لدول حلف الناتو صحيح قدم
الدول النيتو مساعدات عسكريه كبيره
لاوكرانيا هذه المساعدات مكنتها من الصمود
امام روسيا لكن هذه الحرب الان باتت تشكل
اختبارا جادا لوحده مواقف هذه الدول هذا
في ظل التباينات الاخيره حول شكل الدعم
العسكري المسموح به للاوكرانيين وكذلك
ايضا مدى استعداد دول الحلفة لمواجهه
تابعات مساعداته المستمره لاوكرانيا او
حتى امكانيه التصعيد العسكريه مع موسكو
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا المستشار السابق
لقياده حلف النيتو في الولايات المتحده
وايضا الباحث في الشؤون العسكريه الدكتور
موريزي وجيري اولا الدكتور ريزيو اهلا بك
معنا في عسكريتانيا يعني الان عام على
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه لكن بعد كل هذه
الفتره كيف تقيم تعاطي الدول الاوروبيه مع
الموقف والحرب ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا حتى
هذه اللحظه
شكرا لاستضافه في برنامجكم كما شاهدنا
مؤخرا ومع قرار المانيا مؤخرا بارسال
دبابات عقب الخطوه الامريكيه بارسال
دبابات حلفونات الان اقوى من اي وقت مضى
اثر الطلب الذي تقدمت به اوكرانيا
لمساعدتها في تحرير اراضيها من المحتل
الامبريالي الروسي واعتداءاته وعلينا ان
نلاحظ ان هذه هي الحرب الاولى لقوه
النوويه في التاريخ البشريه بالتالي فان
الناتو لا يدافع عن اوكرانيا بل يدافع عن
العالم كله في وجه هذه القوه الامبرياليه
التي تذكرنا بعهد النازيه حين سعى هتلر
لبناء المانيا العظمى من خلال ضم الاقليات
الالمانيه في انحاء البلاد ويبدو بوتين
وكانه يحذو حذوه بضم الاقليه الروسيه في
دول الجوار وقال بصريح العباره ان هدفه
قوات الناتو الى الوضع الذي كانت عليه قبل
1997 اي عندما لم يكن في تحالف الناتو دول
من شرقي اوروبا اي دول الاتفاق وارسو
وفكرته هي بناء روسيا حديثه من خلال الغزو
والاستيلاء على اراضي دول مجاوره مثل
جورجيا في 2008 ثم اوكرانيا 2014 واخيرا
الغزو الشامل لاوكرانيا العام الماضي وبعد
عام من الحرب نرى ان اوكرانيا تصرفت بشكل
جيد وبشجاعه وبتحضير جيد كما كان رد
الناتو جيدا من خلال وحده اعضائه وبصلاحيه
واضحه وهي حمايه اراضي دول الحلف ودعم
شركائه اذ علينا ان نتذكر انه منذ
1994 اصبحت اوكرانيا وغيرها من دول
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق شركاء كما هو
الحال بالنسبه لشركاء الناتو في المتوسط
وفي الخليج ونحن ندعم جميع شركائنا
بالتدريب والمناورات العسكريه
اين كيف تمكنت اوكرانيا بقوه من الصمود
امام هذا العدوان ومؤخرا طلبت اوكرانيا
المزيد من السلاح وخاصه السلاح الثقيله
مثل المدرعات وكذلك الدفاعات الجويه وارسل
الناتو في الشهرين الاخيرين دفعه جويه
لاوكرانيا وحاليا تحاول كل من ايطاليا
وفرنسا ارسال دفاعات جويه وانظمتها
لاوكرانيا وكذلك لاستعاده الاراضي من
الاحتلال الروسي طلبت اوكرانيا بالحصول
على دبابات ومركبات مدرعه متقدمه ووافقت
المانيا مؤخرا على ان ترسل دول اوروبيه
مختلفه دبابات لاوكرانيا من المانيا لان
المانيا هي الدوله المصنعه لهذه الدبابات
لذلك نحتاج الى اذن اعاده تصدير من
المانيا وقامت الولايات المتحده بخطوه
رياضيه بارسال دبابه لاوكرانيا املين بهذا
ان تتمكن القوات الاوكرانيه من استعاده
اراضيها من الاحتلال الروسي وهذه الملامح
التي تتحدث عنها دكتور موريزو
هل تعتقد بان هذه الملامح لن تقتصر خلال
المرحله المقبله على الدفاع من قبل
الاوكرانيين ربما يقوم الجيش الاوكراني
خلال المرحله القادمه بعمليات هجوميه ضد
الجيش الروسي في الشرق او في الجنوب في
دومباس على سبيل المثال
نعم نحن نرى هذه الحرب على انها الاولى
لهذا الجيل الخامس بمعنى استخدام الاسلحه
والانظمه التكنولوجيه المتقدمه وقد كانت
المسيرات التي وصلت من احدى دول الناتو
وهي تركيا مفيده جدا لاوكرانيا لكن في
نهايه الامر عندما تكون هناك قوه احتلال
تسيطر على اراضيك عندها يتسنى عليك
استعاده الاراضي بعمليه عسكريه بريه اي
بالدبابات والمركبات المدرعه وكان من
الطبيعي ان تطالب اوكرانيا في هذه الحاله
بالحصول على دبابات ولتحرير الاراضي انت
بحاجه الى قوه مشاه مسلحه ما يعني ارسال
المزيد من السلاح والذخيره لاوكرانيا
وربما ايضا قوه جويه لان القوه الجويه
بوسعها تقديم التغطيه والدعم للمشاه في
معارك تحرير الاراضي لكن الولايات المتحده
قالت انها ليست مستعده لذلك الدعم الجوي
بعد وان الامر يع
والطغيان والعدوان لاحتلال دول مستقله ذات
سياده هذا ما قام به في الماضي وان استمر
في هذا النظام فانه سيواصل استهداف دول
اخرى مثل دول البلطيق التي فيها اقليه
روسيه وبالتالي يعتبرها اراضيه تابعه له
لكن لا اعتقد انه سيصل الى ذلك الحد لان
اوكرانيا وبمساعده الناتو ستتمكن مع نهايه
العام الذي سيكون العام الثاني لهذه الحرب
ستتمكن من اخراج القوات الروسيه وسيرى
بوتين وبطانته والعسكريه كوزير الدفاع
ورئيس قوه فاجنر انه لا يستطيع الصمود
امام دوله تحارب من اجل الحفاظ على
استقلالها وعندها ستتراجع القوه الروسيه
وستبدا حينها المفاوضات دكتور موريزي
وجيري المستشار السابق لقياده حلف الناتو
في الولايات المتحده وكذلك الباحث في
الشؤون العسكريه شكرا جزيلا على وجودك
معنا
فرقاطه وصف الرئيس الروسي دخولها الخدمه
بالحدث التاريخي والمهم للعالم فيما
اعتبرها وزير دفاعه بان لديها من القدرات
ما يكفي لردع اعداء موسكو في البحر والبرا
الفرقات الروسيه الادمرال جورج هذه الفرقه
يمكنها حمل 24 منصه لاطلاق صواريخ عموديه
منها صواريخ فرض صوتيه من طراز سيركون فرط
الصوتيه كما انها مسلحه ايضا بصواريخ
جواله من طراز كاليبر وكذلك صواريخ مضاده
للسفن اسرع من الصوت من طراز اونيكس هذا
بالاضافه الى منظومه صواريخ بلاش المضاده
لطائرات وكذلك ايضا مدفع بحري من عيار 130
مليمتر وايضا تربضات مضاده للغواصات تم
تزويد الادميرال باحدث منظومات الحرب
الالكترونيه كذلك
[موسيقى]
بعد الفصل انعكاس المساعدات العسكريه
الامريكيه لاوكرانيا على المخزون
الاستراتيجي للجيش الامريكي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الحرب في اوكرانيا وضعت
الجيش الامريكي تحت ضغوط كبيره من جهه
يحاول تامين كل ما تحتاجه اوكرانيا من
مساعدات عسكريه ومن جهه اخرى يحاول الحفاظ
على تفوقه العسكري
الحفاظ على التفوق العسكري الامريكي واحد
من اكثر المسائل الملحه دائما لوشنطن لكنه
الان يكتسب اهميه خاصه في ظل تنامي
القدرات العسكريه الصينيه وكذلك ما تقوم
به بكين من تحديث مستمر لترسانتها
العسكريه لكن الى اي مدى الولايات المتحده
قادره على الحفاظ على تفوقها العسكري خلال
السنوات القادمه خاصه في ظل ما تقوم به من
ارسال لاسلحه الى الاوكرانيين في الوقت
الحالي هذا ما سنناقشه مع السيده اندرو
ماتريك الباحث في برنامج الدراسات
والدفاعيه في مركز امن امريكا الجديده
اولا السيد اندرو يعني على اي مدى برايك
اثرت الحرب في اوكرانيا على استراتيجيه
التسلح الخاصه بالجيش الامريكي في هذه
المرحله
شكرا جزيلا لاستضافه اعتقد ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا وباشكال عديده برهنت على صحه
العديد من افكار الول المتحده الاساسيه في
الشؤون الامنيه واستراتيجيتها العسكريه
للعشرين او الثلاثين عاما الماضيه وهنا
تكمن قيمه الاصدقاء والشركاء والعمل من
خلال الدول التي لديها توجهات متشابهه وفي
مثالنا الحالي تعمل الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها في النيتو عن قرب مع الاوكرانيين
لمقاومه الاعتداء الروسي واعتقد ان هذه
المقاربه اكدت الكثير من الاشياء التي
تحدثت عنها الاداره الامريكيه لكن سيد
اندرو فيما يتعلق بنقاط الضعف التي
اكتشفتها واشنطن في برامج التسلح الخاصه
بها برايك ما هي اكثر نقاط الضعف لفتت
انتباه البنتاجون في هذه المرحله
اعتقد ان اهم ما يركز عليه حاليا في
الحوارات اليوميه هو القاعده الصناعيه
الدفاعيه وصناعه الدفاع وقدرتها على انتاج
وصناعه تشكيله واسعه من القدرات المختلفه
من الدبابات والمدفعيه وصولا الى الطائرات
والقنابل فالاداره والبنتاجون قلقان بسبب
تركيز صناعه الدفاع الامريكيه على الكفاءه
وتحسين القيمه التي يحصل عليها كل دافع
ضرائب مقابل اموال الضرائب التي يدفعها
الا ان ما شاهدناه في اوكرانيا اثبت ان
خوض الحروب المفاجئه والعنيفه يستهلك
كميات كبيره من المواد ووزاره الدفاع تشعر
بان الصناعه الامريكيه ليست لديها القدره
على الانتاج بالنطاق الذي ترغب به الوزاره
في المستقبل
السيد اندرو دائما لا يتوقف العسكريون في
واشنطن عن المطالبه بزياده الميزانيه
العسكريه لكن برايك هذا الامر من قبيل
التمويه انه هناك بالفعل احتياجات للجيش
الامريكي لا تلبيها الاداره
اعتقد ان الجواب عن هذا السؤال هو للاسف
نعم واعتقد ان الجواب يحتمل الاثنين فمن
جهه هناك تنافس مستمر على الموارد بين
الدوائر العسكريه المختلفه هنا في واشنطن
وجزء من ذلك يعود للرغبه في زياده الموارد
والجزء الاخر يعود لاحساس المسؤولين وبشكل
ملح بان امريكا تواجه تحديا يتمثل في
الصين وهو تحدى لم يواجهه المسؤولين بهذا
الحجم منذ نهايه الحرب البارده وهذا ما
دفع العاملين في سياسه امريكا الخارجيه
لتغيير افكارهم الخاصه بالمسائل الدفاعيه
من ناحيه واثر ذلك ايضا على توفير الموارد
فنعم هناك عنصر خاص بالالاعيب
البيروقراطيه وعنصر اخر خاص بجمع الموارد
السيد اندرو يعني خفيا بانه الصين او
الصين الان والتفوق العسكري الصيني في هذه
المرحله من الامور المطلقه جدا لواشنطن
اذا استمرت الصين على هذه الوتيره من
التصنيع العسكري هل سنجد يوما ما تفوق
عسكري صيني على الولايات المتحده
من الصعب جدا الاجابه عن هذا السؤال من
الاشياء التي يجب ان نتذكرها هي ان كل
تنافس عسكريا حدث على مر التاريخ كان له
تاثير تفاعلي فمثلا الصين تتخذ خطوه من
هذا الجانب وامريكا ترد من الجانب الاخر
في بعض المناطق اعتقد ان على امريكا
التعود على التحركات العسكريه الصينيه
العدائيه بسبب العوامل الجغرافيه في
المناطق التي تتنافس عليها الدولتان خاصه
تايوان اما شكل ذلك بعد عشره اعوام او حتى
20 او 39 عاما من الان فمن الصعب جدا
تحديده ولكن بعد كل ما سمع من واشنطن
فهناك قلق متنام حول هذا الامر اما كيف
سيتعامل البلدان فيما بينهما في المستقبل
فكل ذلك سيعتمد على الجانب السياسي
الدينميكيات العسكريه ستفرض بعض الشروط
الا ان الامر يعتمد على القياده السياسيه
واسلوب ادارتها للمواجهه بين البلدين
مستقبلا وهي التي ستقرر في الختام كيفيه
تحقيق التوازن العسكري السيد اندرو لا شك
بانه الشركات الامريكيه استفادت كثيرا
خاصه من الدول التي كانت لديها اسلحه
سوفيتيه وتستبدلها الان باسلحه امريكيه
لكن الى اي مدى الشركات الامريكيه العامله
في مجال الصناعات الدفاعيه قادره على
تلبيه هذا الكم الكبير من الطلبات
هذا سؤال وجيه باشكال عديده اعتقد انهم
متحمسون لتلبيه متطلبات وزاره الدفاع
لزياده الانتاج وتحديث القدرات الدفاعيه
لكن السؤال الاساسي هل بامكانهم بالفعل
تحقيق ذلك واذا ما نظرنا الى تسلح امريكا
من خلال الحرب البارده فانه كان لدينا عده
احواض لبناء السفن التي لم تعد موجوده
الان فالاحواض التي لدينا بامكانها فعل
اشياء رائعه وعظيمه ولكن في الختام اذا ما
كانت الاداره الامريكيه او الكيان السياسي
الامريكي جادا في تفكيره الدفاعي في وجه
الطرف المنافس المتمثل في الصين ولكن
بنطاق يختلف عن الحرب البارده فسيكون
بحاجه الى استثمارات كبيره في راس المال
والمنشات للسماح بقطاع الصناعه لبناء
المزيد من القدرات وبشكل سريع
السيد اندرو الصين يعني تبدي مرونه كبيره
في التعاون مع دول العالم فيما يتعلق
بالصناعات الدفاعيه في حين انه الحكومه
الامريكيه تضع الكثير من الاشتراكات وكذلك
الكثير من العوائق الان يعني هل لا يقلق
هذا الامر الاداره الامري وهل الولايات
المتحده بحاجه الى مراجعه سياساتها
التصديريه المتعلقه بالاسلحه والانظمه
الدفاعيه بشكل كامل حول العالم حتى لا
تخسر شركائها او حلفائها
اعتقد ان هذه واحده من التحديات الموروثه
من مقاربه امريكا القائمه على القيم لدينا
قيم نعتز بها ونريد ان نتاكد من بيعنا
للاسلحه لدول اخرى لا تستخدمها بشكل لا
ندعمه او ان تكون تلك الدول غير متوافقه
ما قيمنا وبسبب ذلك لدينا نظام صارم
للتحقق قبل تصدير الاسلحه وبصراحه هذا
يضعنا في موقف ضعف مقارنه بالصينيين الذين
لا يفعلون ذلك لكن في الختام اعتقد ان
عمليه اتخاذ هذه القرارات يمكن ان يتم
تحسينها لتكون اكثر كفاءه وكما اجبت عن
العديد من الاسئله الامر في الختام يعتمد
على هويه امريكا كدوله كيف تحب ان تظهر
هناك حالات يمكن لامريكا ان تخفف
اجراءاتها في تصدير الاسلحه وفي حالات
اخرى اثبتت ضوابط صادرات امريكا الدفاعيه
انها صحيحه كما انهم يقومون بعمل حيوي وهو
المحافظه على القاعده الصناعيه الدفاعيه
الخاصه بامريكا من الصعب جدا تحقيق
التوازن في هذه المعادله ولا شك ان هناك
مجال للاصلاح ولكن في نفس الوقت هناك
اسباب تدفعها للاستمرار في عملها كما هو
عليه اليوم سيده اندرو ماتريك الباحث في
برنامج الدراسات الدفاعيه في مركز امن
امريكا الجديده للابحاث شكرا جزيلا على
وجودك معنا
مقاتله احيطت صناعتها بسريه بالغه لم تصنع
لاي جيش حول العالم سوى الجيش الامريكي
فقط كان طيروها يعيشون مع اسرهم بالقرب من
القاعده الجويه التي توجد بها في حياه شبه
منعزله هذا حفاظا على سريه عمليتها
المقاتله الهجوميه الامريكيه اف 117
نايتون تعد 117 اول طائره حربيه شبحيه في
العالم اي تعجز شاشات الرادار عن رصدها
طورتها شركه لوكيد مارتن الامريكيه في
مطلع ثمانينيات القرن الماضي وبدات رحلتها
التشغيليه الاولى في العام
تميزت بشكلها الهندسي الفريد والذي جعلها
تبدو من الاسفل وكانها مركبه فضائيه اول
مهمه قتاليه لها كانت في الاجتياح
الامريكيه لبنما في العام
وتمكنت بالفعل انذاك من تدمير رادارات
الدفاع الجوي البناميه
القوات الامريكيه سيطره جويه تامه شاركت
ايضا في حرب الخليج الاولى في العام
1991 واشتهرت بشن غارات عبر اطلاق صواريخ
ذكيه موجهه بالليزر وهي التقنيه التي لم
تكن رائجه في ذلك الوقت في العام 1999
تمكنت القوات اليوغزاليه من اسقاط احدى
هذه المقاتلات بصاروخ سام ويعتقد ان حطام
هذه المقاتله منح روسيا وكذلك الصين فرصه
للاطلاع على تكنولوجيا الشبح وربما نسخها
في مقاتلاتهم تم تصنيعه 46 طائره من طراز
اف17 وبقيت في الخدمه حتى عام 2008 بعد ان
قررت القوات الامريكيه استبدالها بمقاتلات
وكذلك طائرات
[موسيقى]
حلقه عسكري تريا لهذا الاسبوع قد انتهت
الاسبوع المقبل المزيد من الاسلحه والمزيد
من الصفقات في امان الله
[موسيقى]